the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us I'm Yasser and I'm sitting alongside
Vegas we're bringing you a wonderful
summer chess classic make them it's
granted great fun and the rounds have
gone really really fast I'm a little bit
sad that we're almost like ending the
tournament I know we're in the
championship rounds everybody this is
round eight but first of all let's take
a look at the standings after seven
rounds of competition Vegas please do
the honors three three ways tie in group
a between Benjamin book John John Burke
and then Nico Theodore that is insane
they all have four and a half and our
keema shop is going to be most probably
Benjamin and John because they're
playing each other so it's a very
exciting day no question about it that
group a three player tie for first but
now tell us about the group b because I
got a surprise for you there too there
we go even here we have three-way tie
for the first Samuel Lamas of Andrew
Hong actually Chandra with five points
they are leading the tournament
fantastic and tell us begum about the
tournament format for the two events as
we get a view there is two template
around Robin was 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves 30 minutes for the rest
of the game with 30 seconds to increment
throughout the game not much left but
tell us about the remaining schedule so
we are already
yes yeah and then we tournament around
eight today they're playing it right now
and we have the final round tomorrow and
then maybe playoffs in case we have a
tie for the force and uh tomorrow the
round will actually be starting a little
bit earlier will be coming on at 2 p.m 2
p.m two hours round starts at 11 30 a.m
wonderful and as we get started to begin
our broadcast tell the viewers what they
can expect in terms of the pairings
let's start with group a
group a pairings as usual it's great all
of the great great Masters are competing
and our key matchup as we mentioned
before it's Benjamin book versus John
Burke who are the leaders of the
tournament two players tied the first
and let's just jump into that game just
briefly uh the players have just uh
right just came out of the opening and I
personally find this position a little
bit easier for black to play even though
black has these double pawns this Pawn
on C4 is it kind of like in the throat
as it's controlling some very key
squares and the pawn on D2 is backwards
it's remarkable uh begin if you took
that D2 pawn and put it on the D4 Square
that's immediately my position
it's a transformation light goes from
slightly worse to much better they just
like wow and as we mentioned before as
we were talking foreign B3 uh can we go
back a little bit a little bit yes right
here it was a very bold move by Benjamin
Benjamin who thinks I'm sure I will win
the power yeah well you're better the
current position Knight G4 F4 he wanted
to stop this very nasty Queen takes H2
Checkmate business Rook B1 Rook here and
we're up to date with the players a
little bit mystified by that move uh
Rook to B8 you know somehow I'm looking
at that D3 Square I don't know if I
should be playing Queen E6 and Rook D3
or I don't know if I should be playing
Queen D3 immediately it just seems I'm
not 100 sure that that Rook uh Rook to
B8 because now as we were coming on air
you were saying to me yes sir 94 is a
very serious threat maybe he's going to
eat that pause before after all well if
you do everything is also kind of big
for whites exactly tell us about the
pairings for uh Group B as we see a
visual there at the Players the some of
the leaders are competing and trying to
win and we have our key matchup which is
Jacobson versus lamassov Brandon and
Simeon it's a very important game for
both of them because uh La maso is
leading the tournament with five points
alongside Andrew and
but Brandon is catching up people
started the tournament not that great
but now he has four points if he wins
the tournament he's catching up with the
leaders well if he wins the game yeah
he's got to win the tournament yeah uh
and and in this game by the way Brandon
is I'm gonna say a comfortable end game
position it's not that easy there's one
weakness on the board and it's sort of
like to attack that weakness you gotta
Play Moves Like Bishop G3 E4 Bishop F2
otherwise yeah otherwise it's not so
easy to to grab that one Also earlier
you were asking me how you can attack
the pawn on C5 and we were trying to
analyze how where should we put the
bishop and then Bishop G3 Bishop after
seems great yeah it fits the bill from
Black's boy interview black can see what
white wants to do white wants to double
up on the C file bring the bishop to F2
and I think
in these types of positions you kind of
throw the a pawn down it's like a jab
you know you kind of go
you know A5 A4 and you try to make the
B2 Pawn a little bit backwards you look
for counter play on The Queen side uh
for those of you with excellent memories
you will recall the 1972 World Chess
Championship match between Bobby Fischer
and Boris baskey were against A5 Bobby
ended up putting his pawns at an A4 B3
and one what was considered at the time
the game of the match so uh we'll keep a
careful eye on this one and uh tell us
uh began these players have been
fighting very very hard in this
tournament what are they fighting for
they're fighting for some nice prices
okay
thousand dollars second place is four
thousand dollars and third place is
three thousand dollars and then rest of
the players also get some nice prizes
and then total price font of the
tournament is twenty two thousand
dollars thank you St Louis chess club
and in the B group bigger first prizes
four thousand dollars second one two and
a half and third prizes 2 000 with the
total price fund of fourteen thousand
dollars
again very very nice that these classic
tournaments take place here we have four
each and every year and it's been Saint
Louis has has really helped a lot of
players get their norms and it's so
important to just have that competition
as well as you mentioned I think it was
yesterday's two of the slew players are
tied for first let's just jump into the
games right away let's uh go to the game
of act shot Chandra one of our
tournament co-leaders I always like
um going to the leaders at the start of
the round it's sort of like respects you
know playing our respects to everybody
as we get a very conventional uh English
uh kind of what we would call a reverse
dragon
I wasn't sure about E3 Knight d29 C4
idea
E3 yeah oh this is pretty standard stuff
I mean uh I played this on my chess
career I'm used to that now that move is
a little bit surprising for me because
I'm really used to these types of ideas
uh Knight takes Rook takes and the idea
is I'm just putting some moves on the
board for the moment is that we get a
position where the imbalance is I have a
king side majority black has a queen
side majority and I'm always aspiring to
play a3b4 and you know away we go he
actually I would think the decision he
made is because of the tournament
standings akshat thinks that he needs to
win against Slenderman most probably who
is having a bad tournament exactly but
Alex you know it's kind of funny you you
play in the tournament
where one of the highest seeds
is having a bad tournament and people
are
taking points from yeah not only like
points rating points right but it's
dangerous to imagine that you're going
to Target the highest rated player in
the tournaments because they might
suddenly play the best game
because for example especially when you
play Black pieces against them you feel
like draw should be fine but the
question is that they're playing a
bathroom but can I actually try to press
or not here we go they can wake up in a
different mood
okay but akshat has his ideas he's
looking to play the move d4 D5 perhaps
in combination with the move of Knight
takes B6 because then any recapture on
D5 might come to the tempo and here he's
prepping
the big blow 97 is quite an interesting
move what did you expect
I was thinking of
like I thought 90s
90 C5 is following yeah and somehow
white Bishops
uh visually make a very pleasing
impression the the more effective than
blacks Bishops that are still on their
original squares we still consider after
Knight D7 and the move played in the
game uh 97 and and still day five as
well in this position uh doubtlessly uh
when he got to this position Chandra in
his mind was thinking that he would like
a knight to end up being on D5 so maybe
something like this
position I mean it's still nice for
white exactly I mean it's not that's why
I thought my night is placed on E6
better than D7 but maybe I'm wrong uh
yeah uh well Knight D7 Knight E3
uh maybe maybe an intimation that uh
action
76 or 95. yeah he didn't want to
unnecessarily create a weakness on C4
and so he retreated his night night E3
Knight F6 D5 and again akshard is
thinking you know if there's a massive
trade of Pawns
if anybody's better it's me yeah it's
white because that's right
but see if uh it's a very important I
don't know I would say I'm not a fan I'm
not a fan I think I would have just said
okay if you go ahead dude do your worst
I really like Bishop D7 because I I need
to finish my development right clear if
you take on C6 I will talk with the
bishop that's right I do have enough
compensation if you take on uh C6 yeah
it's the bishop I will take back yeah I
did
um split my pawns I do I did create a
weakness but my uh pieces are better
place I feel like well The Rook for the
moment for sure I mean after a move for
example like Queen F3 white can say well
I've got a nibble but okay like the
other game that we were watching there
too yeah uh where there's a weakness on
C5 it's only a weakness if you can
attack it once again black will be
looking to play A5 and A4 uh on the
other hand conversely I want to say the
move C5
wow I I look at that and I say be
careful A4 A5 the Knight Will slip back
to the C4 Square that's a big passer
that's that's and he did play A4 of
course and he did play D6 because that
passer is what it's all about now no
doubt when uh Linderman played the move
C5 he he he pictured this my this
position in his mind and he was thinking
is going all in it feels like today is
the day when he woke up is that movie
with that mood very dangerous
he's risking but A4 created a weakness
on B B3 and you cannot attack on C5 and
your D6 Pawn is weaknesses as well for
weakness as well so structural wise I
think both of them have many weaknesses
but the question is who's going to use
it faster yeah and concretely here in
this moment it's all about this Pawn
right and the move Knight F5 begs the
question could I play the move G6 and I
I've I'm very very cognizant that
yeah yeah like an accident could appear
on that diagonal a very constant uh what
what do you think would have happened
after G6 your first you don't want to
move the Knight because that's the pawn
unless you wanted to play here right uh
could it be that that's the question can
I you know if I take it can you take
ignite do you want night takes D1 I
don't think I'm going to be able to save
this Pawn I'm attacking C5 bonds yeah
right
and then that's what I I'm thinking I'm
thinking the pawn is beyond the supply
line
[Music]
yes please
if you take this right finally using the
weakness of G6 right okay um
six as well
I would love the bishop too F5 continue
the whole line of play there for example
play F5 for example first of all I can
check okay
5 is 5
.95 if I played this you're most
probably on time and we don't have much
right right I I I I I just managed to
hold you in place can I buy sir
faster better stronger faster better
maybe I should go to this position okay
but after Knight D5 I feel I've got Fair
chances of
you know holding the game rookie six or
so yeah yeah okay good good yeah you did
good no that's good Rook check Rook B1 I
I'm
you know I you're holding the position I
feel I feel like this isn't uh scary at
least
yeah I like the the oh we do have uh
quite some moves sorry so he did play by
the way
um after Knight F5 Knight D7 he did not
play the move G6 Knight B1
did you see that
I didn't see that 91 makes sense because
he wants to put his Knight on C4 the
problem is that where exactly where how
about the F5 might if you're going to B1
this is uh this is a stream now I do not
like it at all you don't like it at all
so let's just see I like it at all four
why did I Retreat my knight on B1 and
never put it on like C4 uh
weird decision true but wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait the basically
it's working but right so I have usually
I I have this move Queen E5 give me The
Rook how about Bishop
Bishop G7 do I have any attack that's
the question I'm F6 not really you're
holding F22 Queen G5 is not possible
unfortunately it doesn't seem like it
you're right and the pawn on the pawn on
um D6 I wanted to say is still alive so
be careful so just a second so we do
have this position is on the board oh
sorry no this position on the board is a
rock
and then second this is yes
and I'm anticipating and akshat is
thinking
or
he took on e4 right just now wise
decision and Rook takes
now pause this moment pause for the
moment because
the C6 Pawn is hanging so we could
always take that we do have Rook D1 as
inviting Bishop takes uh D6 walk into a
pin if you like and then we have the
move that looks the most attractive
which is crazy Queen E5 but I wonder if
edit works
can I play Queen B8 perfectly legal
perfectly legal that's that's weird
and then
um I'm threatening Rook B1 yes I know I
see that I see that don't try to trigger
me I will I will try to trick you I
don't know how I'm going to trick you
but I will try uh Rook but for that
reason you need to protect your queen
and still play D7 and then try you need
to threaten the aid which is impossible
right maybe he missed Queen B8 you can
see Lenderman is getting excited
he's like okay let's take time let's see
right
just a second am I missing something
maybe maybe yeah
actually
the ACT shot is Miss has missed this uh
lovely move which not only defends The
Rook but it pins the pawn
it defends The Rook it pins the pawn to
the queen so you don't have to eat the
desirable D7 and that that is it's like
a triple whammy we do we we defend the
Rook attack the Knight and attack the
pawn queen E5 looks like an overreach
and maybe
as if this was all a part of the program
well the problem with
Chad's position
why he's doing this kind of this kind of
fast decisions oh but then Queen E5 was
a bad move exactly a bad move and it
seems like Linderman has 41 minutes
against one minute
the position is not winning by like any
means for black but yeah no time the
time is a huge Factor let's just run
around the horn here a bit and uh again
uh we're gonna just check in on our
Marquee match up and that's the game
between uh Brandon Jacobson and Samuel
samyan Brandon needs a win as he's
trailing by one full point but with a
win he could get on the podium Rook C3
was the last move and here I'm kind of
thinking that it's important because you
you do have a wedge that Bishop that's
not working yeah it's not working and I
do see Bishop G3 to
F2 on White's agenda I like White's
position let's go around the whole yes
sir yes also Bryden is doing everything
oh well no it's like also one of those
things that sometimes uh chess can
appear to be very easy open files what
do we do with the open files we put our
Rook is on the open files open diagonals
what do we do with our Bishops
Outpost so you put your Knights on The
Outpost your Bishop some diagonals and
Rooks on both files your opponent
resigns and then you go wow you played a
great game not really
but this is the rules of strategy
absolutely looking good looking good
here Justin versus Andrew uh well it
seems like it will end in a draw dead
draw dead draw nothing to discuss there
uh Armand versus elshon elshon has been
having
we talk about roller coaster rides he's
been having one this is a very
uh nice and balanced rook and Knight
ending
for Black Black because of the space
once you look at this night is working
nicely first of all it's blockading your
passer but it's doing a yeoman's job
it's double trouble it's blockading and
attacking this king is ready to support
your majority and the Rooks look good so
overall passive passive passive and then
huge problem of the position for black
is that Knight D6 Knight C4 ID is not
working because of Rook C6 and Rook is
protected and you cannot move your
pieces and just King is coming to a
forest right that pin I hate being
written yeah it's very unpleasant
position exactly King f4 on the board
and here you start to look for desperate
ideas like G5 F takes Rook takes uh just
sacrificing upon because in my opinion
if white just you know mundanely is
allowed to plot his way up the board uh
with G5 and G6 he's simply going to win
let's take a look at the game of Luca
for a moment oh whoa what is this two
pawns for an exchange very very powerful
I'm always counting the pawns two pawns
for the extra what Rook G1
uh is that an ambitious move or a high
author I don't know what that move is uh
let's just see the last few moves yeah
that's what I I suspect the Rooks so why
does an interested in trading Rooks
naturally but hiding it on G1 isn't much
of a consolation because well hold on
okay why no no not at all bless you
white wants to put his Knight on D5
I suppose he wants to play G4 King G3
and he's trying to say I have two pawns
against the exchange maybe I can push
them I think that's not going to be
working that way but okay
we'll see we'll go to the other group
for a moment
and check in on our Marquee matchup
because this was the question right here
after the move F4 he played Rook B8 and
then played Queen D3 we talked about
this movie and why do you need the Rook
to be eight maybe the The Rook on A1 to
C1 I'm going to say that's useful for
white if you don't if if you play this
well you see it immediately it's quite
useful for white white is looking to
move the Rook but wait a minute what is
going on here
ah back rank mate sorry I'm like blind
excuse me no they need to play Rook B2
Rook B2 yep and what does Victor coach
and I say weakness is only a weakness if
you can attack it in this case you
you've done everything you could you
can't do anything more and I've got the
weakness defended now by the way I think
things are could easily easily change in
White's favor because
long term I am ready to play night here
Rook takes maybe trade the night and
most probably for that reason I need to
control E4 square right yeah probably
like five okay
so effort so if I'm white in my mind
trade the knights if I trade the knights
and I put my king on E2 I'd say then I
get to play Rook take C4 so all I want
to do is trade Knights so oh yes sir
[Music]
tell us what we said to play if you play
Knight A4 Knight A4 very attractive and
I want to do it
and what it was The Rook with the Rook
oh
okay that's a that's a sweet back rank
Checkmate did you ever see the book
Bobby Fischer teaches chess no it's the
most ridiculous book ever
did you know that it's the most sold
book ever Bobby Fisher teaches chess
it's the biggest seller of all time
there's no other book in the world it's
over a million copies sold wow over one
you can understand why and Bobby Fischer
the world chess champion teaches chess
and the entire book
is devoted to one tactic and one tactic
only and that tactic is exactly
so I'm a kid right I'm 13 years old I
pick up the book this is Bobby Fischer
teaches chess holy smokes I'm ready to
learn the dude's a one-trick pony that's
all he does back rank mates everybody
it's at least now you know
it was ridiculous million copies sold
and it's hilarious
um by the way I forgot to do one very
important thing we have a result oh
absolutely yeah right about it
as we were coming on air the player who
was undefeated drawing all of his games
did did
um
he did a boo-boo it was a huge blunder
by Ilya who drew his seven games and
it's coming in oh It's upsetting I was
rooting for his nine draws as Perfection
against wrong knock
who is actually having a good tournament
even though he started the tournament in
a very bad way he was very upset about
it and now he bounced back exactly
um strangely enough this is a very
theoretical uh variation the two Pawn
sacrifice for white is so dangerous it's
considered the best uh reaction for
black is simply to give back the pawns
the players reach this position and if
anybody has anything and it's very very
marginal it is white and after for
example A Move Like Queenie for Queen
takes Bishop takes E4 if you had told me
that white would press the game for
another 30 moves and the game would be
drawn I'd say salute that's that's I
think that was as foretold Ilya got
maybe
sick of like Trust
really a very cleverly uh found a
wonderful wonderful tactic in the
position and they played the move rookie
one now this is where some controversy
occurs right here right now
as we were coming on we were going oh
dear we think this is a blunder by Ilia
that he played the move rookie one and
his intended tactic fails
the tactic is of course if you take my
queen I take your queen and again maybe
I'm marginally better just like we are
still exchanging the Queens but my Rook
is better than on H1 the question is
what would have happened after Queen
takes E1 yeah just take the queen I lose
an exchange I lose an exchange and the
game so Ilia
had seen this and he had foreseen the
very nice strike Bishop takes H7 check
of course if you take my Bishop I rescue
my queen the check and I pick up your
queen so you don't take my bishop and
this is the position that Ilya had in
his mind that okay now he's threatening
a discovered Checkmate the queen is
hanging this is excellent position for
white just simply excellent and most
probably he also thought that Queen E5
is not working because of Bishop F5
discover check and he decided to play
rookie wall that's exactly right
and then as his opponent is thinking
ilyah came to realize this very painful
discovery that the move Queen E3 any
Bishop Shack will be met by Queen H6
blocking so then the question is okay
now I could play F4 and I'm still in
business but guess what I'm not
attacking the queen anymore and suddenly
black winds through very exacting play
he will end up a rook ahead ili can
resign but the crazy part is Ilya
resigned
of the Moon yeah right which is like
okay crazy let your opponent
at least
[Laughter]
for 20 minutes and Ilya decided to
resign even though I do understand he
was tilted he calculated everything but
why would you still do that right don't
never trust your opponent I think one of
the let your opponent play Rook takes E1
and it was very recent I'm gonna say in
the last two years there was this it's a
wonderful tournament it's the Norway
tournament and it features Magnus
Carlson and just All-Stars so there's
Shack rear mamidara playing against this
one-a-thon Anon Shaq is a little bit
better
a blunder like this yeah oh I do
remember there she's thinking thinking
thinking and Shaq resigns and then visha
asked him
why did you resign so in those moments
let your opponent play the move
you can always resign you cannot unless
it's going to be Checkmate or something
like that
um a little controversy going on here I
think Ilya prematurely resigned he
should have at least waited for running
at least even though he knows it's uh
it's a losing position losing tactic but
still he could play that out just to see
if it's just chickens Spectators exactly
you've got to find the move Queen E3 you
gotta find the move Bishop G4 which is
not easy that's why ronaku was taking
his time he was thinking for 20 minutes
to be sure probably he he was a little
bit shocked and maybe he thought oh
maybe I get caught out of the opening
right you know it's just different
feeling exactly
I'll quickly tell this story because
it's my worst story ever as a chess
commentator worst story ever so what
happened was yo Baba
was winning against Vasily Ivonne Chuck
just winning
and Vasily was just grimly hanging on
hanging on just incredible and somehow
the silly managed to fight his way to a
rook ending where he's worse
so Jehovah is better is better then
Jehovah makes an incredibly strange
decision he offers to trade Rooks and go
into a king and pawn endgame but now
keep in mind Jehovah was better in The
Rook ending so the only reason that you
would offer a king upon endgame is if
you're better in that maybe winning yeah
so the better to me it looks like it
could even be worse anyway before I
could decipher the position and try to
understand this King upon a game
facilities in in the studio
fascinating come and sit down sit next
to me tell me what happened and lastly
when he's talking chess he's like a
dolphin absolutely
thank you very much goodbye
for the audience
for the audience why did your vova
resign
foreign
very quickly
thank you thank you very much that for
the audience could you please give it
move by move show us what you mean it
goes talk talk
12 moves
bridesmaids the the pawns are too far
the king can't keep it and wins for me
yeah
thank you
leaving the studio he says any good
Grandmaster would have seen it instantly
the audience we're gonna take a break
I'm going to take the sword just put in
my tummy and we'll see on the other side
of the break now
in the meantime in the a group E Von
sokolov is watching the broadcast and
he's laughing at my discomfort he's
laughing laughing laughing oh poor gas
or having to deal with that silly next
morning he's at breakfast with
[Music]
um
top Grand Master from Croatia who's
playing in the a group and you know
they're getting their eggs and bacon and
breakfast stuff and sarich says to
sokoloff why did Jehovah resign and he
goes
any good Grandmaster
so it had a ripple
uh you wait for your opponent to find
those good moves right exactly it's not
as easy
not as easy when you're playing
let's jump to the game of the U.S
U.S Champion Mishra just here less than
a month ago uh won a very very uh
tightly fought competition and very
important competition that's how he
qualified for the US National Chess
championships precisely so I'm going to
say he's a happy camper in the idea that
he's got an evenish position he's got
his majority then they're pretty
flexible they're they're not blockaded
white has his majority a little bit
better position for the king but I'm
looking at this Rook coming over and you
know based on my being able to play B4
and Rook A2 I think Mishra is doing fine
that's the thing has a very comfortable
position exactly exactly uh the last
move H4 I like this move just gaining a
little space when you've got a majority
use it absolutely use it and put it to
work get it going and H4 makes a lot of
sense from sassy darush boy talk about a
roller coaster ride uh he
has uh left a lot of points on the table
I want to put it that way he's in a
bishops of opposite color ending but you
know what
if anybody has the advantage it's white
a smidge why well because these pawns
right they're more vulnerable Jack
Bishop Bishop
position position better because it
feels like he has many targets yeah
exactly and Nicholas is coming in uh
tight for first exactly uh in this
moment but he is on the back foot uh
let's go to this game between pranav and
Harem tell us about the draw what what
what have you been discussing so RM is
my friend and when he started the
tournament it's like two rounds in or so
he made two drops I'm like oh no worries
you will make nine draws
I predicted it and every day he comes
out he made it oh he's like so upset I'm
like I I told you and then I've been
annoying him like that teasing and
poking and here we go he's on his way to
make his eighth straw oh my goodness I
love it I love how the game are games
going so far right Anish Gary somewhere
smiling you know very solid I'm not the
only one
uh yeah
um it does feel very very balanced
actually I don't know what to say for
um half open position it's usually about
outposts and in this particular
situation you know you you really need
exactly there's no way like there's no
way that someone is going to yeah I I
would if I were white I'd be playing G3
and King here just to make sure that
this Outpost is not a fatal one and
again if I'm on a good day I hate the
fact that my
structure A2 to C4 is on a light Square
uh that Bishop has the potential of
harassing my pawns if I could play A3 C5
and B4 and maintain the pawns there I'd
be I'd I'd feel like uh I've got nothing
to worry about at the board we get a
very nice view of the player as he's
intensely at work
yeah but you can see he's calm he's dead
Aaron made Seven draws I it's fine I
will make it another one okay well uh
key we'll we'll uh keep our eye on that
one again our Marquee matchup Benjamin
versus John Burkett looks like the
players are going through a liquidation
after the move Rook B2 G5
seems okay I like it okay h 3
huh they both don't wanna risk too much
for sure this is a huge game for uh the
two leaders in the tournament takes
takes Knight B1 and uh Benjamin
yeah 94 takes takes takes takes and it's
like we it was like the vacuum cleaner
just came in the position and just hosed
the whole whole bird is white going to
win a pawn uh can Whiteman each
[Music]
okay Rook to E2
uh let's say if excuse me E4 yeah most
probably it's your best try uh all I'm
trying to do is push the Rook away from
the E Pawn so I will eat here had you at
the very start retreat at The Rook
that's an option but I I try to be
active I was wondering gf6 should hold
worst case I can't believe well this is
usually I used to win upon yeah usually
it's better to just give a
this is the current position we'll keep
an eye on this one I suspect it's closer
to a draw than anything at the moment
but maybe maybe white white can force
his opponent to play accurately this was
the draw this is Nicholas
and as well Mishra
is having a comfortable position and
remind you but we have a result yes in
Group B all right Andrew Hong drew his
game against Justin one all right let's
take a look at that game
um
uh I don't know if this is called the
sugartort system but these systems with
the early
b2b3 I really ascribed to two players
nimsaveich in the 30s he really started
playing these what you might call Indian
openings or flank fianchettos and bent
Larson so I really think that rather
than calling it a zuccher toward it's
more like those two guys did more to
advance the ideas yeah they sure did
nc7c5 and you get these uh again these
structures where you have these hanging
pawns isolated Queen pawns and if you if
you study your structures
um
it really really helps you uh in terms
of
your planning so you study the
structures and your plans become that
much easier to play for me the move Rook
D1 is a strange move the
half open e-file feels like where the
Rooks belong so Rook here Bishop to B1
would be my setup
also with my Rook on B1 I always have
these little nasty ideas of Knight takes
at seven on E1 yeah but unpleasant and
also the feeling yeah the feeling is
like you should always be careful about
Knight E6 Knight F7 to Five Night E5
jumps and also after rookie one you can
play Knight E5 Queen goes somewhere and
then rookie two rookie three Rook H3
ideas yeah Rover ideas okay let's see
what happened Rook D1 Bishop f8 Knight
F1 so a completely different approach by
white his idea that is he wants to put
his knight from D2
to G3 he wants to play more positional
chess
even E3 okay E3 where are you going
you're going to go H3 and Knight G4
whoa okay
C5 Bishop B5
um now uh the the funny part is the
classical chess players with like the
Kappa Blancas of the world let's get
really classical would say that White's
play is all wrong yeah
because basically what you're doing is
you're getting two
um pass pawns on the queen side but
you're giving your opponent the center
so uh
I I want to keep the the the the the
king safe but what I really want to do
of course is I want to activate my my my
Center Mass and usually your pawns don't
get there and D4 is
harder to move after F6 for example D4
or E5 yeah but it is definitely an idea
yeah you're you're going in that
direction to move up the board uh C5 A6
wow look at this uh A2 is hanging in
case of uh oh Bishop B2 is hanging
excuse me much more simple Bishop B2 and
black is again he's very happy to grab a
center Pawn for it your idea is going to
be if you're much easier to implement
isn't it so uh uh Justin captured on CC
X captured on C6 captured on B6
and I don't like the position I I think
that black I have a feeling has done
very well I just wanted to be solid
today
yeah I'm not sure the best tournament
but he's playing against against his
opponent like Junior player right right
yeah yeah lose it yeah
um I'm a little stunned by the move H5
I'm it's not a terrible move or anything
like that I'm just thinking that the
Knight on G4
that was my first reaction I was like I
wonder if Knight on G4 is better or E5
why are you forcing why are you forcing
the Knight to a better Square I'm
I might find myself attracted to moves
like Queen B7 Bishop B5 A5
maybe I mentioned it a moment ago maybe
F6 just you know I got the two Bishops I
really like it I I like Black's position
me too uh okay but now
the night was actually found itself on a
really sweet Outpost I love your idea F6
won't work because G6 is a
heck wow by the way here my you know my
Spidey Sense would be tingling if I was
black I would be like wait a minute if I
opponent as a dark Square Bishop you
never want to see Bishop Bishop come to
F6 that would be like I told you before
our generation
right
uh whoa uh that's going in the wrong
direction isn't it I mean don't you want
to go how about F6 H6 right don't you
want to go in that I mean it's a it's a
pity
Bobby Fischer teaches chess it's a pity
you have a back rank problem because you
know
uh these ideas you you know come to your
mind except oops uh Bobby Fischer
teaches Jazz but Checkmate Queen D3 D4
must play by the way I think that that's
a force move if you allow Bishop D4 just
give it up you're just your Bishop yeah
it's terrible you're but now your Bishop
you're going to be a pawn down
what
pricing
as there is blood yeah I'm really
stunned by what's going on here because
Andrew was just permitted to go into a
bishop by the way big shout out to a
production team they are Johnny on the
spot
Bobby Fisher teaches Chas begum and you
could learn what about I will make sure
to research
just look
okay let's oh my God
how many bad cranking
okay this is not really a background but
it's the weakness of background yeah
great mates yeah
oh wow
[Laughter]
he's a one-trick pony
okay I can solve them in like half an
hour I guess all of them right because
it's the same trap
Alaska's you're a genius but chess
genius but isn't that funny
oh my God I got this great gift I got
Bobby Fischer cheese
Champion I thought you're a little bit
sarcastic about it I know
I thought once I read the world
champions book I would become world
champion I would just inhale all of his
knowledge dude it's a one-trick pony
I mean what crazy crazy we have another
draw too as in the game between
Luca and help me out with um
foreign
easy for you to say
uh another draw uh as we have this nimso
Indian with F2 F3 what is it called
is it like a modern
English I don't know but uh it became
popularized by a very Dynamic player in
the 90s Alexi shirov
he did so much to popularize by the way
he has a great book fire on the board
fire on the board now that is a book
that is just really uh commendable uh
effort for sure I have heard that one of
the reasons why he didn't because
Champion is that he
strategy in general himself and his
style a lot but it felt like it feels
like he put his heart to that book yeah
well true true that I would say the
reason he didn't become a world champion
is because he had two of the greatest
chess Geniuses who ever lived
playing at the same time and they were
Anatoly garbage
there are many other reasons in general
I have heard this story right
it's an interesting one uh okay it ends
up like Luke ahead and sacrificed his
Exchange
for a couple of these pawns and this is
where where we saw it and Luca was
trying for something but no I mean these
the Rooks it's not that the Rooks uh uh
materially speaking black isn't that
badly off
the problem is the Rooks are so good
I mean they're really good this is the
love Rooks on the second yeah yeah you
could just lose the game uh badly and
the game that's strange the game was
agreed to draw here black cannot do
anything the problem is that they cannot
attack before Pawn if you play Rook B4
or Rook B2 attacking before Pawn yes the
95 and you cannot kick the Knight out of
D5 as well no no the Knight is
permanently anchored
um I suppose he just felt like black was
going to go King King
and more or less there would be a kind
of a stasis here uh impossible for
either player to break the I think I
just stay King G3 King G4 and exactly
exactly the night stock The Rook start
and then if Knight a king is on E5 most
probably I do have ideas of like moving
my knight actually 97 we cannot take 96
and everything most probably I cannot
never reach this Pawn I shouldn't
because Knight gets trapped yeah be
careful
in general I have like extra move coming
there and coming back exactly okay it
looked to my eyes to be a well-played
game Let's jump to the game of Aram and
Alshon this was the game when we came in
we felt like uh Alshon was definitely on
the back foot you talked about moving G
pawn and it's
well it was a kind of a desperate
measure unfortunately I mean he is not a
happy camper he's a pawn down
you did and there is a chance for him to
hold it
I don't know holding uh this is really
really really tough so for example let's
just what do we say about past Pawns
baby let's see those past pawns get put
so what happens after C5 well we cannot
play our Rook here that would be a
discovered check but otherwise the
problem is that if I move it somewhere I
got a code
Knight C7 Knight C7 I'm sorry I
discovered Jack
that's the problem right I'm I can play
B3 okay and then hope that my bone is
stronger enough to hold a draw and also
night is not placed perfectly but night
before can be the next move exactly oh
night before actually Rook D4 rookie for
attacks Texan P2 here we go there's your
camera play there's your counter play
baby
um I don't know it it's it's some extra
pawns for white so look let me play
Devil's Advocate a bit I'm thinking
about Bobby Fischer's background I got
it on the brain
C8 it's not me but you know what I mean
I'm thinking or you can play Rook E6 is
a great move because that's what you
should do right Rook end games yeah
exactly and now you're kind of
threatening maybe rupee 66 or p8 that
one's a nice one so let's just put that
on the board for just a moment and uh
we're going to make a very bad move on
okay let's go
Bobby Fisher
grateful that you're we've studied his
book
there we have it uh elshon in trouble
Brandon Jacobson and um
samyan we left it I was saying A5 that's
the jabbing move you need to do a little
bit uh of
I think the simplest way of saying it is
provocation you as black you don't want
white to just hold everything yeah you
know on a good day I don't know the king
could come to see three maybe menace's
C4 I like the move Bishop A4 maybe the
move B3 you know it's something you want
to keep in advance
yeah and this was
I want to get my king I don't like
Bishop this would be more or less my
dream right I can't get anything better
than this I mean this is this is my
dream when I play the move B3 I have it
in mind uh vegan that my opponent is
going to always get in the move A4 and
harass me
unless I make a big commitment and play
the move a for myself yeah that's that
was my idea probably I thought he can
play A4 here and then put the King on C3
still correct and then Rook D2 Aqua has
a root and it feels like if I exchange
the Rooks my position should be winning
winning is always strong but that's a
that's a isn't it the British have that
beautiful expression is it better
uh my mother's British so I have license
to speak oh really oh yes oh yes I lived
in the United States for 50 years and
speaks with a British accent today I
know it's crazy right A4 Rook C3 and I'm
feeling
Brandon's idea actually yes it's on B3
yeah I'll take with the bishop and then
I have a passport on a
so you you uh Anything You Can Do I Can
Do Better kind of thing so you
know I is in in semian's uh position if
you go back to this moment right here
I think black is worse only because of
the split pawns put that pawn on B4 and
I don't think we have anything to talk
about
but because of the split pawns I think
black is trying to make a draw and if we
do
if he achieves it he's success he
succeeded so I don't know if Brandon did
well with that move B3 let's let's go
where would you like to take us uh clock
shots leaders you know this did he make
the time control because actually when
we left it actually he just made
had only
one minute right this is this is a very
funny game well funny game a funny move
a strange move that neither begum or I
could grasp and that was the move Knight
we want you told me in Sicilian when you
your opponent Place G4 and his plan to
play G5 right yeah you play Knight t7
and it's like that too he played A4 and
landerman's like why wouldn't we just go
back
well I would say this move for me Knight
B1 that is a real uh head scratcher and
I think it was all based on the game uh
what happened to the game because you
know oftentimes you you see these
forcing lines everything that's an
attack
capture capture attack these forcing
lines are very very narrow path and I
think mentally akshot foresaw this
position foresaw the move Queen E5 and
just thought I'm doing great
stop
this is one of the most spectacular
defensive moves I've seen in quite some
time in the sense that
we love double attacks those are the man
90 95 of all tactics are double attacks
this one is a triple this is an amazing
tactical sequence that just finished
the move Queen d8 defends The Rook
that's tactic Memoir it attacks the
Knight on B1 but it pins the pawn to the
queen so he does three things
so it's just like it's an amazing move
and X shot in time trouble
uh ended up playing Knight C3 now if you
just go back a move before you played
the move Queen E5 I could have taken
yeah
taken we would have reached the exact
same position as the players achieved in
the game but I extracted
C6 so we could definitely say the move
Queen B8 was missed yes absolutely and
also like Knight B1 I I was playing this
Parham so last round after Abu Dhabi
[Music]
and that's what I wanted to say
and and I was white pieces so he's a
strong opponent anyways yeah it's not
like I lost the game because I played
Knight P1 but I really did lost the game
because I went back with my knight on B1
and he did the similar thing as
landerman did he made like moves which
put problems like and then I while I was
trying to solve those my knight couldn't
move and it was under attack he played a
great game and it's just I I got my
lesson okay you just don't go
Sometimes some you know the great maybe
work but in such situations when
everything is hanging it's better to
keep the night close to the center
exactly well as a great Bobby Fischer
himself said sometimes
you're the teacher and sometimes you're
the student uh there you go fortunately
most of the time
ah you're young you're looking you've
got this bright future you've got lots
of losses ahead of you to look forward
to
uh Rook A2 Alex Linderman he's a pawn up
he's he's mistreating one of our
tournament leaders here as he
is really enjoying his extra pawn and I
think 55 is not working unfortunately
because of Bishop cheat Primo
Rook D5 is not working because if Bishop
takes G3
um if you check on d8 I can just
clicking
and if you check in G8 you just move
your King right so this is the current
position the Knight is hanging
The Rook is hanging and I have loath I
hate I always hate to walk into these
pins yeah and funny thing is that is
that if you even check on d8 you would
deny it doesn't have any good squares
right
well we've we've spoken about that for
uh throughout the broadcast and it's a
isn't it it's
um a word I I take from the Japanese
game of Go and that is to suji to suji
is a Japanese uh word where a move that
is played dominates the opposing
it's interesting that when the knights
and the Bishops their interaction when
the bishop says two squares away from
the Knight it kind of dominates the
night so if you think about it this
night moves what you were saying
it doesn't have very many squares and if
you have to go for example to a backward
square like this yeah so is it just lost
by the way it could be just hot shot is
so upset and he just played Rook D5 but
can I just take on G3
picture takes g3s
um I believe
he's hoping against hope
that uh but this should be easy winning
just took on G3 actually took H text G3
and Rook B5 but and King G2 or
he played Rook D7 I I don't like that
actually you're absolutely right you
just you know
uh you can just see uh this is one of
the things I want to say that I missed
about the whole pandemic
is literally chess moved online we
couldn't go anywhere so we're standing
at home we're watching the players play
online and mostly you can't play
classical channels online it's very very
I never played any tournaments right but
Blitz and Rapid you could and
everybody's playing Blitz and Rapid but
when you look in person and the two
competitors are you know side by side if
you will against each other you can see
the expression of action
yeah
pounding the table and discuss when it's
online
you lose all of those tells that feeling
of like I'm winning and uh Linderman
definitely two pawns Up Now Tell me uh
I'll make the following I I hate my
position I'm two pawns down but I want
to put my Rook on
then I still can improve my
I wanted to ask you how are you going to
how are you going to I mean your your
two extra pawns so you think oh this
should be easy no I I do believe it's
not easy yes sir but it's not easy I do
believe it's not
especially rookie games are the most
tricky one of them exactly in games out
there right but I I do believe it should
be video I do I do I do I do I think
Rooks B2 makes a lot of sense to me Rook
B2 Rooks the salmon Rook C2 rugby two
because I'm holding your king as well
Roxy too and I'm going to G5 most
probably 25 good and I
if I had left my king on F1 I'm not a
happy camper I I have another idea
instead of G5 I could play H5 and put
the King on E8 and you cannot attack
none of my for example King f8 King E3
King E8
right that could be another idea and
this is a this is essentially this
position for what it's worth I'm not
saying I'm a happy camper I'm two pawns
down is White's idea yeah because
if you think about it
the three versus two somehow yeah two
points are holding people it's a little
bit Miracle exactly that's why I feel
like I should play G in G5 that was your
your was your initial Instinct yeah it
was to play G5 maybe just I don't know
you just get this position and then you
just figure out uh what your next steps
are Maybe h5hwara
so also H5 H4 because I like it I'm
tethered to my f Palm yeah and and if
you try to win my H form most probably I
can't
I'm not even sure how I'm supposed to go
Oh you mean something like check check
yeah and then eventually I force you to
allow me to attack my age poem well in
this case I'm going to go check King E5
and Rook
Maybe
can I protect my well
okay it's a little bit
Rook C3 King
but this should be winning my C phone
should should win it yeah I I would my
king is too active agreed agreed uh
Lenderman two pounds to the good we have
determined after
here it comes are you ready
one of the great books we just talked
about fire on board one of the great
books was Grandmaster preparation yeah
my Grandmaster left Polly guyevsky and
left polygayevsky had the polygievsky
variation the night or Sicilian an
unbelievably ridiculously Ultra sharp
opening you defense you don't even want
to go there I mean Madness
is uh the end game in that variation
anyway Lev
he loved analyzing and he would come to
these positions
his output was prodigious
and then at the end of this output he
would say after
painstaking analysis drop you know like
this but this word
painstaking like he did he had to put
his whole you know
Dostoyevsky he had to put his whole uh
life uh into uh his work it was glorious
reading painstaking analysis and so far
players are following our ideas
King G2 was played on the board I wonder
if Linderman's gonna play G5 or not
you know it's funny uh you play Just C4
C4 you know something like never mind
I'm not gonna decide yet sometimes you
just push him you just push him I was
afraid if I push it then I cannot push
my other Pawns
but his idea is to play Rook C1 and then
uh get the pawn on C2 and then just try
to move with the king king of it King E8
King d8 right that's how you do get
there and then eventually you do have G5
and H5 also in the pocket uh for akshot
who came into today's round one of the
players uh tied for the lead this is
painful this is painful let's jump to
the game of Brandon and also we have a
result in a or um successfully made his
eighth straw what do you do I'm hoping
over here you predicted uh perfect I'm
proud of myself yeah sir yeah uh jumping
into the game of branded for a moment
because we were thinking that
um the game was more or less balanced uh
not 100 sure Simeon
wow uh okay that decision is interesting
first of all it's not taking the pawn
too right first of all I am taking on B3
regardless you know
a b let's get a b a b on the board you
know that kind of a thing uh I'm
surprised somehow this Pawn on E5 feels
like I really like it yeah so don't you
think he just created for himself
another weakness on E6 yeah I think so
if you take a b right now oh wow
okay we have a very players are very
ambitious truly I don't like Lex I don't
like black smooth you don't but I'm I
don't know
why would I create
um so you could yes or you have it
it's just too far away my king is close
Okay but
uh
let's put it like this
one of the things that I I love about
Chess I love about jazz is this idea
that it's a battle
of ideas
you have your ideas I have my ideas
let's say who's this whose ideas are
better now before you say bad bad bad
black is making a statement black
statement is I have a potential past
Pawn on the king side I have one on the
queen side already
you have already a past pawn and
but your your passers are doubled yeah
so black is trying to say my past pawns
are better than yours whether it's right
or wrong that's not it yeah that's what
the Battle of ideas is all about and I
love it now tell me why you think it's
bad what black has done okay before I
say it
we need to know that they were having
time scramble here so they just made
move forward okay gotcha okay
that it's hard to judge when you have
time scrambling right but I feel like
um please tell us White's position is
better because I'm playing A4 and next
move A6 okay A4 A6 I feel like my
passport is
um for the more like from Advance yes
than yours for example you cannot really
play C4 because not uh King D4 I always
win your Pawn there okay and if you play
G4 where today I can play G4 okay so let
me play H4 H4 then maybe A6 what you
want
to go G4
King F4 I think king of force now
this is the Battle of ideas right this
is your idea so I I was thinking after
each form probably I should play H3 but
after G4 I'm only looking at four
uh I'm sorry A6
okay H3 G4 King F4
I'm playing this I
[Music]
wait you get to play your moves I get to
play my moves
then my idea is to play this ah
but there is a problem right you can
play this and then I will I'm forced to
play this
um
then you're happy it's over then you're
happy you tricked me
um that's my idea and and what were you
saying sorry about this one this one and
then Bishop G2 right and then A6 okay
now this one this one strikes me
as
A7 crazy I I'm not sure because your
look is you know what I want to say is
like an event A7 C4
Rook A8 now let me get rid of that a
pawn yeah
uh I yeah Rook A8 hero uh that a pawn
bothers me
I got some trickies just do these things
right
you have your tricks right I have my
tricks tricks I agree with it
it's one of those things that
you're right it's in time trouble
to make the judgment and it's very very
awkward to assess whose past pawns are
more dangerous one of the uh scary parts
about
uh the double A pawns is precisely that
they've doubled a bonds sometimes you
know
if one of the pawns were on B6 or B2
it'd be a completely different matter
um and it wouldn't surprise me if in
this case if Brandon has misjudged the
ending in the sense that like yourself
Brandon probably saw his Pawn on E5 is
this great stall work of a tower of
strength and his King is being a little
bit better than this kind of passive
black king but looking deeper into the
position it's not easy H4 G4 G3 is a
tactic oh actually maybe I have another
idea for example
but like still after G4 I have Bishop E2
idea okay and if you play A4 H4 I still
can't believe you should be two yes of
course you can I mean and absolutely uh
in this case
you're kind of giving up on
I don't know uh you're you know no it's
not easy yeah sir but maybe it's better
than what I did
fair fair uh it's just uh it's a very
difficult position we're going to let
the players
boil over it we do have another result
in the game between Mishra and yeah
sassy
uh when we left it we thought afterwards
okay somewhere around these parts we
thought the move Rook A8 coming was
going to give Mishra easy equality
and
well but that was an interesting trade
of Pawns how that occurred and not too
much happened uh begin they just wow
they just agreed on a draft
funny funny moment to agree to a drop
was E5 played I don't think so no I
don't actually believe that I think that
I think it's I think they must they were
analyzing something must work or they
just pushed upon you know right right
right uh oftentimes uh the players they
don't put the king in the and they're
analyzing yeah yeah like that kind of
thing so a draw in that match uh darush
it's a very exciting game between
Nicholas and Darius which are
former Saint Louis students right and
again uh Nicholas is coming into this
round one of the players tied for first
uh when we left it we kind of thought
that he was struggling a little bit with
black maybe his struggles are over I'm
looking at the position what's the
problem I'm going to play G5 h g h g I'm
gonna start trading off more and more
pawns and for Nicholas this will be a
great result it kind of keeps him in
that first place mix especially uh I
think it's actually a result for Darius
as well
don't you think so well he was pressing
he was pressing but like he's having
such a like uh roller coaster event and
sometimes like true it's like fine and
in your
life yeah
eternally uh three uh two versus one
and in this particular case the two G3
and H4 versus F7
I want to say
has zero chances of winning like it's
it's unbelievable this is your best pawn
against the G3 and H
a g and H ponds versus S F Pawn the
defender is just great yeah you're just
fine I will
oh no I lost the game and my coach was
like you need to just remember just um I
was a kid I understand
yes sir I understand we've been there
we've all been there one thing that's
very interesting is Imagine white has an
F4 Pawn Yeah I have F4
G3
and H5 let's just say and I'm going to
give you upon a black pawn so you're
black you're defending
where will you put the three versus two
where would you put the black pawn in
hand what is the best defensive setup of
three people age six of Salon yeah
I was wondering I was thinking of that
yeah because there are some structures
when you have F6 F7 H7 or H6 pawns H7
Pawn is better than your HG and H Pawn
Yeah in some cases Victor korchnoy
taught me that in a three versus two the
best defensive setup is double Death
Punch
here we go
you learned that on your own but the
doubled F bonds because if you think
about it white with the three Pawns at
some point he's going to go H4 G4 F4
then he's gonna go fi G5 and that double
F1 trades itself off and then it's
waiting for you to play G6 and it trades
itself off and then it's a draw so this
game is going to be a draw uh we think
Darwish is going to be a draw and by the
way we we're missing our uh interviews
because we're not getting that many uh
wins today exactly
[Music]
by the way the pawn is here uh on uh on
on A4 I want to ask you a quick question
if you don't mind if I play the movie C4
so the idea was to stop you from playing
Bishop G2 if you play King D4 just
saying just saying and if I play H4
let's
well
what's the story
time that was my question
yeah
yeah so you're tricky
well the idea is and I can still take on
G4 G3 you know we saw perform as a check
yeah we saw those uh types I wonder if
white is in trouble
well that's that's one of those uh we
have what we call in chess these cold
shower moments where
you know it's hot and heavy the the
fight has been great you just made the
time control
and then as you started thinking and you
kind of calm down calm down you come to
this quiet realization your destination
and it's the cold shower feeling of like
where did I go wrong
because you're like okay I feel like my
position is not that's great but like it
if I survive
the district and then suddenly you
survive and you're like wait a second
it's terrible right I've got no tricks I
got nothing oh my goodness so this could
be a cold shower moment
Brandon as he realizes he hasn't uh
saved the day now go into the game of it
I have many Rook end games today yeah
exciting it is a a day for Rook endings
the way
I liked your idea of
uh slurping that pawn on A6 uh armor and
then but I think the difference you can
see the idea of work E6 or B6 which was
your idea and so strong it's contrary
everything well for the moment he does
have this awesome I mean that is oh that
should rain that's that can that is just
such a great king but how is he
escorting his pawns precisely
eight F6 maybe F6 B2 okay tell me which
movie you like F6 immediately yeah let's
play F6 simulator okay I don't know what
I'm doing I'm gonna just play no you're
trying to trick me with rookie three
that's the only trick you have
well spotted I am indeed trying to trick
Megan with rookie three check yeah I'm
just wondering yeah
Rook B1
Rook P1 get out of the trick
get out of my dirty rotten idea I am
wondering what if I walk in your shirt
like C6 Rook E3 yes sex text Queen B1
Queen yeah yes and then C7
wow if you play for example Queen a to
check I play King The King D6 chicken
discover check and queen
but I think sometimes you study too many
uh studies
and you forget the queen is a really
good piece
yeah I don't think you want to go here
but I don't like I do like specifics no
go go go for it I do like uh rugby one
just uh I don't know Rook D2 yes C6 no
maybe even you're winning yeah I do just
make it
a simple chat yeah pawns are just too
strong I think so too uh I think elshon
is likely to lose this game Brandon
again this yeah and he has played that
H4 I didn't know whether to include the
move C4 maybe after the move A6 uh G4
but I don't like I want to go to you
Bishop T2 I like that moment not only
it's like protecting against G4 but it's
protecting against Rook F3 after Rook f8
which is a great uh like open five one
file for blog they suddenly didn't have
much no there's no bit we like to say
the business squares are all protected
the business squares on an open file be
being F1 F2 F3 in this particular case
are all
nice I really like Bishop E2 move yeah I
do too with the idea of playing A6 as
well I definitely and then I can play H3
Bishop G4 worst case and then that's a
good idea actually maybe I'm not winning
but I am not losing for sure as well uh
when we left it act shot uh you know do
we we were watching him as he's just
like in this oh this very very painful
situation he comes into this round uh
scoring very very well he was
um tight for the first but at this
moment he's two points down I have a
question for you can I go no I can't go
on a rampage
the Rampage was unfortunately right Rook
takes King here and I'm Dreaming shorts
idea is not working because I can't even
play Four yes can I just play a four F
four wow okay that is a surprise King E8
is working but like how about F4
F4 wow um now I'm a little bit confused
uh if he takes you too
and just simple chassis too
and King H6
uh
I can check Rook H2 King G5 and then
King
of fate
is this so clear though uh no you came
back
[Music]
um
I'm just not a uh
yeah I
maybe you're still winning but I need to
check yeah I it it has the feeling for
me of confusion I don't know if it if
yeah
maybe it's just still I know I could do
everything without F4 but I'm just like
right being mean
uh I I rejected it for another reason as
well and uh that other reason was just
simply I didn't believe that uh it was
enough here yeah Kenya fade is simply it
should be winning exactly just run away
but wait then I can take on H7
take on age seven I think if four is a
good move yes sir now I am looking at it
maybe it is it is because but after F4
you can play G4 which is
n't and then I can play King of it yeah
it makes sense
uh two extra pawns there are some
puzzles like that in the end you should
play like F4 so King doesn't come to F6
and then you can just play C2 and right
like yes exactly yeah yeah probably it's
not the most precise one but hey if it's
effective
no that's me that was my uh
unfortunately I cannot see I was trying
to I was trying to mix it up and and you
know that's one of the things I think
that people misunderstand also about uh
the sport of Chess and I I use that word
deliberately the sport of Chess I'm
losing end of story you're winning end
of story
I cannot give up
I must do everything in my power to
resist absolutely and to make your life
as difficult as possible to to put every
obstacle in your way if you answer all
of the puzzles yeah well done so don't
give up this is very important
absolutely any sports absolutely you it
is your job when you're in a bad
position a losing position doesn't
matter you have to try your hardest and
I think that is what being a champion is
all about it's not just like
winning brilliantly and being a great
player and doing all no it's about
saving those really hard tough games I
think it's one of the like moments that
shows why you're great exactly exactly
and that's an important
equality uh to have this idea that
you're really gonna do your best and
you're gonna resist okay where would you
like to take us he did flaking it for
you okay I mean he knows actually knows
that if he that's the only if he just
waits around uh eventually you know Alex
is going to play here I just wondered
can I just put f
it's weird but like can I just play H6
I think it's the same thing I'm still
doing my best to uh mix it up I like
your uh Rook takes F2 check by the way
how many pawns did you win
I liked your F4 because the whole idea
King F6 F takes G3 Jack is
that's but yes sir there's another point
after a foreign
there are some positions when uh
actually white can hold because like for
example if it's like H5 King G5 right
it's already a truck it's so weird but
it's one of the few situations when you
can make control with white
unfortunately this is 27. yeah this
isn't one of those drawing positions I
know what you mean of that mechanism and
I did play on an Olympia team
um in Moscow in 1994 and Alex you're
malinski was two pawns down two
connected past pawns down in his game
and you know we had given him up for
lost in his opponent allowed one of
those blocked positions and he saved
this absolutely lost game and it was a
real it was a very very important half
point that he saved for the team King f4
on the board Rook takes uh King G4 but
regardless of whether or not this is one
of those drawing positions you're right
again as as white you're doing your
absolute best to make uh it possible
make it as difficult as possible for you
upon by the way did we look at G4 no
that's what I was going to tell you okay
of course is another idea right the
thing is that if I play King of f8 yes
now you're just taking on
well now I'm happy right I finally I got
rid of
a very important thing I I wasn't a fan
of C4 and C3 idea to be honest like he
had to play he had to play G5 yeah G5
H6 King f8 you know
don't rush
King F4 by the way let me just uh put
this on the board refresh where you
actually you're a top king of four sorry
once again we've been looking for a few
minutes
before uh it's getting tricky again
right it is
because I I have a question is it is it
even winning it doesn't seem like it no
I mean I can always you know bail with a
check right you're losing your F4 yeah
I'm losing my pawns yes sir what I think
we're just am I blind I think I am blind
too like why would I play F4 why
wouldn't we just go back to D2 or B2
like
rugby too yeah exactly right and what
what we are doing I think Rook D2 is
better because if you play King H6 I
just can play C2 and then still I have
uh like change the check yeah and Rook
H2 check also to run away yeah yeah I
think I think that's how Humanity okay
we're gonna take this Pawn
27 and then King GC G7 it's okay yeah
sir I will give you this luxury of
putting your king of the beautiful
Square can I just be very passive and
play Just Rook F7 King j7 and yeah
yes you can and that should be enough
uh wow uh it's so rare for us we're so
used to getting so many guests uh we're
having so many victories to have so many
draws is a bit of a surprise but with
this number of draws already in the
books let's just take a look at our
standings absolutely and group a it has
been a slow day but not for around night
not at all I won his game against Ilya
and now he's
clear first that is insane with five
points and then tie for second between
Benjamin bogg John Burke and Nichols
Theodore who are playing their games
right now we expect Nicholas to draw to
draw to draw to tie with her neck also
Benjamin Benjamin John they are playing
each other which means they will draw
and they will have five points at least
we're expecting well potentially uh
oh if anyone's going to win it it's
going to be Benjamin but uh in the uh a
group Benjamin is upon up we do expect
the game to be a draw which would mean
that for tomorrow
it's all it's all up for grabs loving it
I don't know about the playoffs
closing ceremony dinner yes sir it's
fine is it you will make it you will I'm
worried I'm worried I'm excited about
tiebrex I hope we'll have tie breaks in
both sections in both playoffs uh and
what about the group b
Group B so far Andrew Hong is the solo
leader of the tournament who ended his
game with Justin in a draw and he has
five and a half points but we still have
time four seconds with action Chandra
and similar Manos of five points but so
far we think actually just losing his
game unfortunately and La manosa namazov
most probably will make a draw right so
again
and then maybe extra it just depends in
trouble for sure and before we sign off
or do any of those things we have some
really really announcements the first of
which is the Fisher random tournament is
coming up uh and it promises to be fan
Fantastic I know the field
I got an advanced view but Advanced Peak
and let me tell you it is incredibly
strong like ridiculously strong not even
one of the but it's many
is excited to bully them by the way oh
yes because we are starting it with
ultimate meant most exactly the ultimate
moves is one of those events where it's
trash talking trash talking is not just
allowed it's encouraged
come with your insults and uh you better
be ready you know I got in a great
shot yeah uh Lavon aronian
he was on the opposing team don't ask me
why
somehow I got recruited onto Rex's team
which included Gary Kasparov and
um Magnus Carlson oh my God Magnus
Carlson
that day Magnus or yeah that day Magnus
Carlson had lost a playoff against
England in the single cup he had lost
the playoff
the players were rotating in comes
Madness
and he sits down and he's playing in
Lavon aronian shouts Magnus this is the
best position you had the whole day
because he had just lost
he's my teammate Magnus so what did I
immediately answer with
immediately answer like lickety split
milliseconds
here it comes at least he's still
playing
meaning he got to the playoff and you
didn't
push but
ouch
so you gotta get in those Jabs and
ultimately to watch and to play exactly
we're so excited about the tournament it
was fun it was fun and by the way Gary
uh he he gets into it too like oh
Harry's a competitor he why anything
chess why didn't you play this why
didn't you put
he's still got that competitive Zeal
again as we get ready to sign off we do
think
and we have been so wrong we've left
Benjamin was completely wiping or losing
he ends up winning I mean it's like
crazy and finally he has a position
which is like predictable predictive we
hope we hope we're right when we say uh
John Burke is going to draw this one we
hope well did we really look at this no
this isn't it has changed it's changed
well it was Bishops of opposite colors
oh look at this tricky wait he didn't
play G5
wow we're saying he needs to push G5 and
F4 correct
that is a surprise
and ah well wait a minute wait a minute
that is crazy because of the players
defined a way to fight right
you feel like there's nothing correct we
thought this we were giving up this game
for drawn but with these double pawns uh
there's
there's chances let's put it that way I
think this chances for darush at the
moment the very active King right we do
have ideas of Czech and king of three I
I would be scared with white I just
don't like it's just unpleasant that
like King comes to F3 or like H3 okay
let's do something concretely right so I
do want to give you a check and in the
immortal words of of Nikolai nineve gift
me your Pawn
can I play King H3 I'm just yes yes I I
I looked it and then I looked it up it's
in the rulebook you can
and let me try to gobble up your Pawns
should I get greedy
five look at five E4 rookie A5
okay A5 G4
take it okay four
I think we're gonna make a draw take it
and I think we'll probably uh call that
the day on that one just uh last last
Gander at this all-important game
between akshot and um
Linderman ax shot two pawns down but
somehow you know he's doing his darndest
bestest he's got a very active King a
very active Rook
I think the material should be winning
for black you're you've got good
instincts on this I mean you've been uh
predicting the results so I'm not gonna
argue with you Megan what's going to
happen in this game I have a feeling
after Rooker fate King G8 group F7 King
j7 it should be over so Rook Cafe
oh you're we're going King G5 back yeah
of course
I'm not gonna
put G8 then yes okay
hmm
I don't I definitely enough exactly
funnily enough I didn't have to waste a
Tempo waste the tempo taking this
all-important C Pawn but keeping up that
um
initiative I want to say
C2 here
C2 is it a good try threatening the
Perpetual oh never mind I have to play c
c to immediately instead of Rook f8
to immediately okay now you're yeah look
at fate King G5 King just seven gotcha
now you've got my brain is working
but it was a little bit of a struggle I
mean I still see two Kingdom
exactly
I'll catch up with you C2 I think C2
King G5 is the best try but then
what happens here sorry taking a
feedback king of six in King F6 bug
gotcha so that moral I see so this is uh
well again we were just talking about
this absolute
requirement if you want to become a
world champion
learn to resist do your best in bad
positions and for akshot uh he's doing
his best
what
rookies
no no this is kid though well you have
to find a good move so rookie seven is a
Beautiful lyric of Fate Carol is as I
did
well maybe it's difficult uh Brandon
this is interesting I've I'm seeing
three results here I don't think it's
just uh it's hard to predict especially
especially why it has 10 minutes and
then lamasa has 16 minutes that's very
useful to have that extra time and
lastly we do expect that Aram is winning
against uh elshon because he's marching
his King to C7 hopefully and then trying
to
Queen
tricky rook and Rook rook and partner
endings today yeah there you go thank
you wonderful uh Championship rounds
tomorrow excited we are going it's all
about crowning Champions here in St
Louis and in case there's any ties for
first tomorrow will be the championship
round date but also playoffs if
necessary and also we are starting
around at 11 30 and we will start the
broadcast at 2 p.m Central Time summer
chess classic coming up tomorrow don't
miss it thank you for being with us
thank you see you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited